my dear brothers and sisters this is a
reminder about the first 10 days of the
hija so tomorrow Monday will be the
first 10 first day of the hijab and if
you're going to sacrifice then you're
not allowed to take from your hair or
your nose or from your bed and also a
nebulance also have told us that the the
righteous actions during the the first
10 days of the hijab is better than any
time so carrying out righteous actions
uh was asked what is better to pray to
rock art during the day in the on the
first day this was a hija or two
in the the days of Ramadan the first the
the first 10 days of the hija is much
better to look at
the days of Ramadan as for the night of
course the night Ramadan is better so
let us inshallah all of us strive to do
rushed actions during the first 10 days
of the hijab especially fasting the
knife of uh the knife of the hijab which
is the day of arafah